Hello freak bitches, shit from him. Put Cosby out. Oh God, was this,
that was a surprise. Yeah.
Was it done? Did you, did you ever hear the rumors? No.
See I did in show business circles because, uh,
briefly I lived in the actor's world right when I was on news radio and I would
hear it, I would hear it back then that he would drug people. Yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, you would hear it. Wow.
It was like one of those weird rumors that would go around bill Cosby drugs
people. Wow. Dude, it was going on forever.
That's why Hannibal talked about it when Hannibal talked about it on stage and
then it all blew up, which is kind of crazy if you know Hannibal, you know guys,
he just happened to be talking about it and then someone happened to be filming
it and then the rest of the world was like, is that true? Is that true?
Cause bill Cosby's always telling people to not swear and tell him,
especially like he was big on telling young black comedians not swear enough to
talk about sex. And he's like, cause he goes,
bill Cosby only tell now at least I'm out raping people. And everybody's like,
what?
Yeah.
That was like the rumor was always around. Yeah, I didn't,
I had heard some creepy, a little creepiness that, but I didn't know.
But it was that extent when someone know
when someone does something like that to people, like that's one of the,
like that's one of the creepiest fucking things a human can do to another human.
Yeah.
And the idea that this guy who was America's father,
right. In a lot of ways, he was our black dad. You know,
he was the moral authority. He was, he was mr Huxtable. Yeah. You know,
and then the fact that that guy,
someone described him as the biggest serial rapist in the history of America,
like that really might be the case because if he really did drug all these
people that he said he did, like how many people have raped more?
He might be number one,
which is crazy. And it's crazy. And the whole time with their hip
[inaudible] yeah. He's the darkest motherfucker ever dark,
dark drug in them. Watching them Plaza. That's fucking,
and he's got kids that's even more fucked up.
The crazy part when you feel someone else's baby and sticking his Dick in them
while they're unconscious, it's so evil. It's evil.
Now what about Harvey Weinstein? Yeah. Woo woo.
And he's the one everyone knew about too, apparently. Apparently. Yeah,
that's the um, that's like, that's the cliche, right?
The disgusting boss of the studio that wants you to suck his Dick and I had to
get a role. I know it's funny because you do think like, well,
isn't that kind of why you become like a show business executive?
Like to get chicks, not to rape chicks. Sexual assault is always off the table,
but, but did he rape them or did, now it's coming out that there's,
there's rape. I tip last I checked today, uh, I know he's,
and he is not a Looker, like he's definitely not cute type of guy.
That would be the type of guy he is, which is what's fucked up. Suicide threat
prompts. Police response. Whoa. Where there, huh?
[inaudible] into a fight with his daughter this morning and they had to,
she called the nine one one damn cause he was going to kill himself or
something. I don't know.
Well he must be so overwhelmed with guilt and fear and remorse and just self
hatred and you know, he sounds like an addict, you know? Yeah.
Yeah. And that he's also probably a power addict. You know,
like he's this guy who's like this gluttonous man.
Like if you look at his physical self, right? His face is over flowing on his
color and he's just gluttonous food. Where's the Coke? Plus
there's this gluttonous existence.
It's not like a measured thought out,
contemplated introspective existence where he's just trying to enjoy his time
here. Like wow,
how lucky I am that I get to do this and make these amazing movies.
You guys were all great. Like that's all I expect from like Steven Spielberg.
I expect Steven Spielberg to be like this really like introspective,
thoughtful guy. I was just enjoying the process of making amazing movies,
but he's, but he's a creative thing. Harvey's an executive guy, right?
He's the guy, the money guy behind everything. And I carve, it's like my deck
is so nasty, so gross. But okay, now on the other hand,
on the other hand, I was like, you know,
Hollywood is such a labyrinth in terms of like getting shit done and getting
deals closed and how did this, does this happen?
It would kind of be nice to be like, you want to Netflix special,
just go fucking suck. And then I could be like, Oh, that's all I have to do.
It's like that guys. Yeah, come over here. You nasty. Fuck.
And then there's a special right.
Way easier would you have to have a conversation with Tommy? Listen Tommy,
this is not sex. This is said job. It's work. Right?
And then it's like cut and dry and it's an exchange. You know,
I was in law school for two weeks and I remember two weeks, two weeks,
and I dropped out in contract law.
It's an exchange of something for something else.
It seems fucking pretty straightforward. Well that's what prostitution is,
right? Which is one of the weirdest things that massage is legal,
but prostitution. Isn't that something? It is.
It is odd because we do not like genital pleasure.
We don't like genital pleasure for cash.
Like general pleasure has to be for love and has to be love and it has to be
given free.
It's the only thing in civilization that we require to be given away for free.
Everything else you can exchange money for exchange money for food. Right.
It's not a prostitution. If someone cooks for you. Right. That's normal.
It's a total normal thing, but it's a very intimate thing. Feeding someone. Yes,
yes, of course. It's loud. A hair salon,
they'll wash your head to give you a head massage.
That's one thing I miss about having hair. I rubbed my head. Ah,
massage or foot massage. People who love foot massage.
I bet there's people out there that like foot massage is one thing like head.
Ah, yeah, for sure. For sure. For sure. Right.
But then you put a camera in front of two people fucking,
and now it's legal. So what's well retarded. Yeah. That makes no sense.
Babies. Yeah. We're grown up babies,
but maybe because you can commodify that and that's a capitalistic thing.
Maybe it's more commodifiable as a product.
Honestly I think there's two, two factors. One is the tax factor.
It's very difficult to get taxes from people that are prostitutes. Right?
It's like no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, not wait,
where's that money going? Give us. Give us our cut. Yeah.
And then the other thing is the um, sex trafficking,
sex slavery aspect,
like protecting people that are sex traffickers because like, you know,
you could have someone that was sold into sex slavery or you know,
in some way bartered their, you know,
trip to America and had some sort of a sex slave deal.
That's where it gets fucked up.
But there has been arguments that what makes that exist in the first place is
that prostitution is illegal here and a prostitution was legal.
It would be that stuff would all go away.
Much like the argument is with illegal drugs.
Like if you made marijuana illegal,
you wouldn't have as much of the Mexican drug trade, which you are seeing,
you know you are seeing in America.
Of course it's retarded and I wait, but wait, Harvey,
he was the guy that would give girls the shoulder rubs.
He would tell them to massage him. Oh, he would massage them.
They would massage him. He would do according to these girls.
I don't know if it's true, but he'd be the guy that'd be like,
I'll be right back. And he comes back in a bathrobe. He's a bathrobe guy.
Here's the thing, here's the thing.
I don't mean to make light of anybody's sexual assault or whatever it was or
harassment, but other working on the roof. Again, wonderful. But, but what I,
but here's the thing. How many women said yes, probably a fuck load.
Like that was his move. What we're seeing is his missed pitches. Right, right.
He hit a lot of fucking triples and home runs,
knocked a lot of balls out of the park,
but occasionally he was Wiffen occasionally. He was like,
I got this one in the bag boys. And she's like, fuck off you pig. And he's like,
Oh, come on. Just come back to my room. No, no, no. It's like, shit.
What happened? Harvey wasn't connecting. I wasn't connecting, but listen,
I got all this.
I was just a girl wants to be in the next fucking this movie and avatar 16
willing to do the thing to get the part and that's kind of okay. Yeah.
Then dense like that guys,
they can get the part and get your money and get on with it.
How many girls read the story when it broke and could still taste the asparagus?
Caviar flavored come just the cocaine and
VOD color in his loads.
I bet he has like a Flemmi like moan when he comes.
He's a kind of guy, the white spittle and the corners of his mouth.
When he talks to you, he's try to hit on you.
He's got a little white bubble lip. Oh,
he nasty. He's nasty. Nasty. But that's a gluttonous man.
He's out of control. It's not attractive. It's definitely not. Oh,
my favorite too is that he would jerk off into, did you hear this?
That he plants, Oh he's green.
He wants to exist off of his loads.
But that's such a desperate thing like come over, can we get it? Can I have it?
No. Okay. Stay here then let me,
you know like it's so maybe it was hoping they would just dive on the grenade
of a soldier. But I also like, I was thinking too, like I've,
I've seen so many dudes jerking off in public like homeless guys.
I never got anything for it. Is it, you know, good point.
Yeah. Young guys. Look just the,
here's the thing about male sex versus female sex, right.
Is the accepting part of female sex versus the giving,
like trying to get, take this, take it. Yeah.
And the other thing is that men take it literally are constantly building com
while you're alive, your com is backing up. Yup.
So if you're, if you're not like I used to have the bit in my act that was,
it was really based on advice that I used to give friends when they're like,
Ooh, girl wants to get married.
I listen to me jerk off first and then think about it. I give you,
if you're having a hard time with someone and you're,
you don't know what to do and you're going to see them jerk off first and then
see them and then you'll be able to deal with them without any sexual lust,
you won't be make it. ISIS cause me as a PR, as a young man,
this is a real issue with me. When I was in my twenties because I was so horny,
it was like I was a drug addict. So I'd be like,
I'd be like making agreements with myself. Yeah, she's annoying,
but she's going to let me have sex with her. So listen, just,
let's just change our behavior and mold to what she likes and then you'll get to
fuck her is, that's what you need. Like otherwise you'd just be beaten off.
But I remember one time I was supposed to go out with this girl and she was just
so preposterously annoying.
It was so frustrating and she just was always negative. And before we went out,
before I went to go get her, I jerked off and I was sitting there, I was going,
what am I doing? Like I don't even enjoy her company.
Like she's not compatible with me. Like I don't if you can,
if you would just like someone as a person and you like having sex with them,
that's a relationship. But if you only like having sex with them,
you have some sort of a weird barter deal. And that's a lot of men.
A lot of men. And I'm sure a lot of women probably too,
but I can only speak for men like men get involved in these relationships where
you're really just in a relationship so that you have a continuous supply of
sex. Especially when you're young and stupid. When you're 20 years old,
you're basically a monkey. You know, you're, you're just like a little,
a person just trying to fuck and you just try to love her. She's really cool.
And why do you love her?
Cause she smells good cause her tits feel good in your mouth. Like what?
What is really going on? Like,
do you actually enjoy her company as a human being outside of sex?
It doesn't matter, right? Most of the time you don't.
And so if you could just jerk off first and then hang out with someone and you
actually liked them,
like then you have a real relationship like Oh I really like you.
I like you clear out the pipes. Right. You clear out the testosterone.
And I think clearly, yeah, it's super smart. But I think,
I mean I'm just guessing, I've never been a a media mogul,
but I would imagine there's a bunch of factors going on. First of all,
there's a bunch of people that are constantly kissing his ass and rubbing.
Like I saw a picture of him with Renee Zellweger and Renee Zellweger was like
cuddling up with him and she had her hand on him and he had his arm on her and
there was like some other celebrity to his right and there were like Yuk Yuk Yuk
it up. But he was like pawn her. He had a hold of her.
And I would imagine that there's all these people that recognize that he's this
like epicenter of power and success.
And you want Harvey Weinstein of Mira max to love you and you would get close to
him and you have a couple of drinks and you're doing Coke together. Yeah,
look at that.
She's got her hand on his leg and he's got Russell Crowe to his right and Renee
Zellweger to his left and she's smiling.
They're probably hammered and everyone's on Xanax. Next thing you know,
he's got his Dick in her butt. That's crazy, dude.
She's like imagining that diary number two, number six.
I don't know if that really happened,
but my point is that it's not just that he was predatory,
it was also that he lived, I'm just guessing. Okay.
I'm not an apologist folks,
but I would imagine that he lived in this world where he was like royalty.
He was essentially like the King of this empire. Right.
So you had all these employees is one of the articles that I read today,
I think it was from the Telegraph where this guy was saying that, um,
he was at a party or one of his friends was at a party and uh,
they were having a conversation with, uh,
this girl who worked for Harvey and Harvey just said her name from across the
room and her face went pale and she immediately just ran away from him to run to
her. Like didn't say, excuse me, I'll be right back. Just ran at a fear.
Who knows? That is obvious. Could he be interpretation after the fact?
It could be exaggeration of what the actual circumstances were to fit a
narrative,
but you got to imagine that this guy is just multi-multi millionaire,
just orgiastic gluttonous
job of the hut, motherfucker.
Just getting us to socked and just [inaudible] we're going to be the biggest,
the biggest driver.
And then there's also these girls that he can't get and he's like close to them,
close to them. That's the anger, right? Listen Christina,
I think you're the one that got his hand on you. One of the best.
Come into my room. Let's talk about this. I've got a proposal,
I've got a proposal. He come up to his room and he's got a bathrobe on.
You're like, what is there? Just give me a massage and my neck is tense.
You're like, Coke, what about cocaine? Caviar, cocaine, caviar together. So
that is, he is unbelievably the him and I have to say,
and I know Hugh Hefner was a big mogul and he did a lot of cool shit.
Not for me.
That would be a tough gig to like living in the mansion and being one of the
girls like come over for movie night, you know,
and he's in his pajamas and you know that he butts sex them because he don't
want to get anyone pregnant. That's the trick. That's what I read.
And what does it, Holly, Holly Madison wrote, but I wrote a book.
Is that her fucking name? Dolly Madison's the pastry.
Like who the fuck is,
he bought sex them so that they didn't have to worry about birth controls?
Correct.
And then there's a lot of like he would make the girls make out in front of him
and then he would masturbate too. It's also kind of,
I think is a way of avoiding possible pregnancies. Wow.
So you've probably developed a strategy of a years of like ducking pregnancies.
Wow. That's, that's a weird thing to write,
to like be putting yourself out there as this person with a lot of money who
really likes young girls and the young girls go,
all I have to do is catch one load.
It's all at the right time.
Stories about athletes that girls put holes in the condoms or the girl girls
take the condoms out of the trash and squirt them into their pussy.
Imagine. How was I born, mommy? Well,
it's a lovely story. Umami. Umami took a condom,
like one of them pastry bags and squirted that fucker in there.
Well, your mother fish to fill the condom out of the trash.
I threw it in the toilet, tended to throw it in the toilet,
but I had one saved in my mouth. Spit that one in the toilet.
And that's why you're alive.
[inaudible].